hey Doug Walker here you're probably
wondering why there's not a nostalgia
critic today it's because I've been sick
for the past couple of weeks and if
you're wondering what it is I just had
on here it's the adenovirus which the
doctor hasn't like officially called it
that because it's just some sort of
virus come around but I mean it really
sounds like this one it's one where you
get like the chills you get congested
you can hear my voice
I got pinkeye and I pretty much get it
once a year now I've gotten in the past
three years and what really sucks about
is that even when you start to feel
better it'll suddenly just come back and
be like fuck you in it and make you feel
worse so the because I think I I
couldn't really cover that up and here
my voice is this is enter the best sound
in a while so yeah it's hopefully
getting better but you can never tell
with this so I'm just crossing my
fingers cuz I'm going to this kind
called fan world and Niagara Falls and I
really want to get better for that but
this thing usually takes anywhere from
like two to three weeks there's three
weeks you could get like a bacterial
infection which is the past two times I
have and I don't get sick I only get
sick with this one goddamn virus I get
every year and it's just bullshit I hate
it but yeah that's the reason why so
what we're gonna do is Irish on
editorial hello oh fuck
so this week there's not gonna be an NC
next week we're gonna run the editorial
that I shot and then after that we're
gonna do get right back on schedule with
the reviews I don't know if it's gonna
be the Rocky and Bullwinkle one or the
one after it so the schedule is still
gonna be the same you know next week's
an editorial next week so regular review
it's just this week I can't get the
review out because I could never get to
the point where my voice sounded okay
and I need my voice for it and then the
pinkeye happened
it doesn't look too bad now but if you
saw it before it was nasty it was so
fucking nasty yeah I'm really sorry I
hate missing work I hate making a video
to you guys and it's just the sickness
is the only thing they can do it cuz
it's just it didn't sound right this is
really the best it sound in a while so
hoping I can rest up and see you guys at
the convention the apart from some sort
of other weird shit going on the NC
should go back to normal
I don't know the next mole I have a
charity shout out cuz again I don't know
if this will sound really good to it but
yeah that's about it guys I'm so sorry
just you know life happens and sickness
happens and hopefully I can keep getting
some good stuff to you so just keep
watching more in seas are coming and
they should be really good take care